ANDREW GERRAND: Hello.
Hi, everyone.
My name's Andrew Gerrand,
and I am on the Go Team.
And I'll just get everyone to
introduce ourselves, starting
with Robert on the right.
ROBERT GRIESEMER: Hi, I'm
Robert Griesemer.
I'm working on the Go Team.
ROB PIKE: Hi, I'm Rob
Pike and we're all
working on the Go Team.
DAVID SYMONDS: I'm
David Symonds.
IAN TAYLOR: Ian Taylor.
SAMEER AJMANI: Sameer Ajmani.
BRAD FITZPATRICK: Brad
Fitzpatrick.
ANDREW GERRAND: And so this is
basically just a freeform
session about Go.
We have a Google Moderator
link online which people
watching the live stream
can contribute to.
I don't have the link handy.
So if you want to find it, just
search for something--
I'm not sure.
Good luck.
You found the live stream
well enough.
You should be able
to find the link.
But otherwise, maybe just a
little bit about what's going
on recently.
Can I get a show of hands, who
here uses Go regularly?
Whee, that's great.
Really gratifying to see.
So as probably most of you
know, we released our 1.1
earlier this week.
That's a really nice
milestone for us.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
About a year on from 1.0, and
we're pretty happy with the
progress so far.
It's been really great meeting
people over the past few days
at I/O, and over the past couple
of days hearing about
what you guys have been doing.
But now we'd really like to turn
it over to you and hear
your questions and tell
you what's going on.
Does anybody have anything?
IAN TAYLOR: [INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW GERRAND: Oh, the
microphone's here.
We might start with a question
from the Google Moderator.
NIGEL TAO: So this
is Nigel Tao.
Also on the Go Team,
just off the video.
Just for the record, the Google
Moderator link is
goo.gl/8sG1h in case anyone
wants to know.
But of course live questions
are welcome.
We have two microphones up.
But whilst we're waiting,
I'll just go off
the top of the moderator.
So the first question is from
Fulum from South Africa.
So [? Dee ?]
[? Vikhov, ?]
Dimitri [? Minix, ?]
[? Remy ?]
[INAUDIBLE], Brad Fitz, et al,
are doing an awesome job of
tearing apart the runtime and
the standard library and
putting it back together,
but faster.
Can you discuss your
big N ideas?
One less than N less than 5
for making Go programs go
faster for Go 1.2.
BRAD FITZPATRICK: I just run
things under a profiler and
see what's at the top.
And a lot of the times lately,
I've been seeing that we
allocate lots of garbage.
So I've been trying to
get rid of garbage.
But it was just something I was
doing towards the end when
there's nothing else to do.
I don't know how long it'll
remain a focus.
But it's definitely fun, and
there's a lot of people
focusing on performance now.
We can't break APIs, so we can
make things faster with the
existing APIs.
ROB PIKE: Well, the tooling
can get a lot better.
One of the best ways to make
Go programs go faster is to
control how much garbage
you generate.
Because the garbage collector,
no matter how good we make it,
is always going to be
potentially a slow spot.
Best thing to do is
to avoid garbage.
So we're worrying about trying
to get the compilers to detect
more cases where an allocation
can be placed on the stack and
things like that.
The compilers are also do better
inlining and better
optimizations.
We're also spending a lot of
time looking at the runtime.
We have a long list of things to
do involving improving how
the stack is implemented,
how the scheduler works.
Trying to make it work better
with maybe using lock-free
algorithms in some parts
of the runtime.
So the step from Go 1.0 to 1.1
was, depending on your
program, anywhere from not much
faster, to we've heard
stories of people running on
big machines seeing 10x in
some cases.
But typically 30-40%,
something like that.
And I'm sure we can get another
significant speedup
for the next round by
concentrating on the
internals, and the tooling,
and also the APIs.
But I want to stress that you
can find ways to make your own
programs go faster by
using the tools
that are already available.
The profiling tools
are very good.
ANDREW GERRAND: Yeah.
It's probably worth mentioning
that straight after 1.1,
immediately all of the people
who've been hacking on the
runtime jumped in with a whole
lot of more stuff that they've
had sitting on their
machines, were just
waiting to mail it out.
So there's a lot of activity
in that area going on.
AUDIENCE: Recently there's
been some articles about
importing source and
being able to
tag them with versions.
Do you plan to address
that anytime soon?
ANDREW GERRAND: This
has come up a lot.
Because of the way Go Get works,
we use the import parts
to identify the location of
repositories and then fetch
code automatically, but
currently there's no way to
version those things.
And the idea behind the design
of that system was that people
would keep the head of their
repositories clean and stable,
but in practice it obviously
doesn't work like that.
And I think there's a lot of
space in the greater Go
ecosystem to introduce better
tooling to make that easier.
I've seen some really
interesting designs recently
for Tools that would let you
take a snapshot of the state
of your work space and then be
able to replicate that state
in other places.
So working in teams and
stuff like that.
But I think it's not a problem
inherent in the design, but
rather something that just needs
to be finessed more.
And it's something that
increasingly has been coming
to our attention.
It's kind of hard for us because
working on the core we
don't suffer from
that as much.
But I can definitely see how
it affects other people.
It's been hard for us to think
about the problem, as it's not
a problem that we have
so much ourselves.
But I think it's something
that's going
to be solved soon.
It definitely has my
attention at least.
AUDIENCE: On a slightly related
note, are there any
plans to support, say, compiled
Go libraries.
From Go to use other Go
libraries, as opposed to
everything just being
static binary?
ROB PIKE: It's something I'd
certainly like to see.
It's a tooling issue entirely,
to do Dynamic Link.
First of all, it does work
with GCC Go today.
But we don't have any immediate
plans to make it
work in the GC Compiler
tool chain.
But we have all the basic
building blocks needed for it,
so I hope it'll happen
and I think it will.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
First off, I'd just like to
say I like the look of Go.
It seems like a great language
and a good successor to C. I
don't know if it's been
considered, but personally I'd
love to see it as an option on
Android for Development.
I think it would be a
very good fit there.
That's not the question
though.
Like many people who use a bunch
of different languages,
there's some features I'd
love to see in Go.
And I wonder if they were
considered, and if they were
decided against for any
particular reason.
I think the primary one would
be more expressions than
statements.
So the "if," the "try," various
language constructs
are statements in Go, which
means that you need vars
rather than vowels a lot of the
time and you can't use as
much immutability.
Did you consider making
"if" an expression?
And if you decided
against it, why?
ROBERT GRIESEMER: I think this
is your [INAUDIBLE].
ROB PIKE: All right.
I was trying to fob
that one off.
I actually really like the
idea of expressions as
computable things, like "if"
statements and so on.
I've even implemented similar
functionality in other languages.
It didn't really come
up in the design.
I don't think it was
deliberately left out.
We were just trying to keep the
control flow really clean
and simple.
The control structures, although
at first glance look
a lot like C or Java or
something like that.
They're actually quite a
bit simpler-- they've
been reduced a lot.
I don't remember consciously
saying we'd want to not do
that, it just never came about
and I don't feel the
pressure for it.
One of the things we did do was
dramatically reduce the
number of things that from
C would be treatable as
expressions, like assignments,
pre-increment, post-increment,
stuff like that.
And we made those explicitly
statements, because that has a
very strong effect on the
simplicity of the
specification.
You have much less to write
about where things happen,
when things happen in the order
of evaluation by making
those not be expressions.
And almost every C program that
ever went down badly had
a misuse of that property, so
just taking it away was a
simplification.
But as far as making "if"
be an expression, it
just never came up.
It wasn't a deliberate
omission.
ROBERT GRIESEMER: I think one
of the common questions is
probably the question
mark colon operator.
And I think that was probably
deliberately left out.
But if "if" were an expression,
then other
questions come up and I think
the kind of code you would
write would start to look
a little bit different.
And as it is right now, you can
more or less say, unless
you'd have function calls, of
course, or method calls.
If you're an expression, it's
essentially an expression
that's side-effect free.
But if you have things like
control flowy things in your
code, then that might
look different.
It might be different to reason
about those programs.
I think it would be a
different language.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: So going back into
performance, I actually wanted
to talk about how Go interfaces
with cgo.
And I noticed that going from
Go 1.03 to 1.1, the
performance in terms of
interfacing with cgo improved
dramatically.
I saw a huge, almost 30x
performance in certain
programs that use cgo, which I
though was really freaking
awesome, actually.
But I also saw some random bugs
which were not in 1.03
that were in 1.1.
Some seg faults in [? Seeland ?]
which I'm still
working through.
And in general, I just wanted
to know if you guys had any
more documentation on how these
things are implemented?
How implementation changed
from 1.03 to 1.1?
I took a quick look, and
everything's very broad--
there's nothing nitty-gritty.
I know I could always read the
source code, but that's very
daunting at times.
So I don't know if you guys
have any white papers or
research documents?
SAMEER AJMANI: Specifically for
Seagull, we did beef up
the docs on cgo quite a bit on
how it works internally.
If you go and look at
golang.org/cmd/cgo, you go
down to the bottom, we've added
a couple more pages on
what it generates and how it
interacts, but there's no
white paper on how it
all fits together.
More documentation
is always good.
Certainly no one's going
to say otherwise.
ANDREW GERRAND: Actually, I
think that that documentation
is not actually in
the web page.
You have to look at doc.go
in the cgo directory.
And it's a comment past the
package comment that's quite a
long, detailed discussion
of the implementation.
So that might be illuminating.
It was certainly illuminating
to me to read.
AUDIENCE: OK, cool.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I asked a question in the
previous session, and they
asked me to ask it here.
Is there any special debugging
or anything we should know
about with App Engine in Go?
We can run an App Engine app
locally on our machine.
Can we use all these tools
to debug there, too?
DAVID SYMONDS: You can't yet,
but it's on our radar.
It's coming down the pipeline,
we just have to get to it--
but yes, coming soon.
ROB PIKE: We actually want to
make Go be the best language
for App Engine, and part of that
is making the tool for it
be really awesome.
So you should expect to see some
wonderful stuff at some
point soon.
How's that?
AUDIENCE: Hey there.
I was wondering if you could
just provide a little bit more
insight as to the extent of
the use of Go at Google.
The description on the
Go language site
is relatively brief.
And it just mentions a couple
things like oh, it's in use at
YouTube, and it kind of
leaves it at that.
This ties into a separate
thing that we've had
discussions about in the office,
where we primarily do
consulting work for clients.
And at times we've thought that
Go seemed like a great
match for what we wanted to do,
but there was discussion
about how heavily vested Google
was in the language.
And I hate to invoke the phrase,
but you often hear
nobody ever got fired
for choosing Java.
And I really want to advocate
use of Go, but it's been a bit
of a black box as to how certain
development on it is
in terms of resources being
allocated to it.
And I think in recent months
we've seen a lot of really
promising things and a lot of
great features coming out, so
I'm willing to stand up
and make a harder
push for it next time.
But I'm still curious
to hear a little bit
about how it's used.
ROB PIKE: I want to point out
that although Google pays our
salaries, Go is an open source
project completely.
So it's a fair question--
we'll answer it.
But I want to make it clear that
it's very different from
Java, which was a Sun product
that was pushed by a company,
had a massive marketing
budget.
Go is a project that we're
allowed to work on as part of
working for Google because it
helps Google, which I'll talk
about in a second, but it is
really an open source project.
Far more people work on Go
outside Google than at Google,
by orders of magnitude.
It's a much, much
bigger number.
So don't conflate Go and
Java that way, I
think that's unfair.
As far as Go's use internally
at Google,
there's a number of projects--
Brad could probably talk about
one in particular--
that are not as well known.
But there's the YouTube thing.
Brad talked about
download server.
There's a tremendous amount of
external facing traffic that
you don't see as a Go program
because it's a Google service.
But a lot of bits flow through
Google's production clusters
serving stuff relevant to
users, and the amount is
growing rapidly.
There's a lot of teams
picking it up.
There's some key infrastructure
that's built in it.
We don't talk about it, but we
don't talk about the C++ use
internally, either--
it's internal stuff.
But the growth is really highly
important, and I think strategic.
Although that's just
me talking,
that's not Google talking.
Do you want to talk
about stuff, Brad?
BRAD FITZPATRICK: Oh, sure.
I was going to talk about the
Google download server this
year, but I think I'll be
talking about it later.
But all the Google download
server was
rewritten from C++ to Go.
And I'm working with three or
four other teams right now
that are porting large systems
from C++ to Go.
Just about every big system
at Google generally has a
lifetime of a couple years.
And when that comes up time to
rewrite it or redesign it, a
lot of those teams are now
asking themselves why they're
writing in C++.
And a lot of them are picking
Go, because--
I mean, if you guys write
Go you know why.
Sometimes you don't
really need C++.
It just happens that as a
historical accident Google had
lots of C++ libraries, so just
everyone wrote in C++.
IAN TAYLOR: I was recently
looking at the numbers, and
over the last year and a half
the use of Go at Google has
gone up by an order
of magnitude.
I can't tell you the numbers,
but it is going up.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So Go on App Engine,
unless there's been an
announcement recently, is
still experimental?
And full tech search on App
Engine is still experimental,
so I'm probably asking
a nexus of extremely
experimental questions.
But there seem to be full tech
search docs stubs for Go on
App Engine.
Is that supported in an
experimental sense and just
not documented?
Or is it not even possible
to use at this point,
and can we get it?
DAVID SYMONDS: Go being
experimental, we don't see it
that way, our team, to a degree
that the software we're
putting out, we are standing
behind and not going to change
randomly and so on.
So we're not treating it as an
experiment in that sense.
It means that when we support
APIs, we want to come up with
a good API design, one
that we're happy to
stick behind for years.
We do have a full tech search
API being worked on.
It's just not quite done
yet, but it's coming.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So, a few months ago I picked up
a Chromebook about the time
that I rediscovered Go and
started playing with both of
them and started going
through the tour.
And one of the things that I
realized is that they really
fit really well together.
Go would be a great platform
to be running on top of a
Chromebook.
And, in fact, you might even be
able to make a shell out of
that and replace
Kosh with Gosh.
And you have already a really
strong metaphor of channels
with co-routines or Go
routines being the
applications that you could
actually be launching.
And the only thing that's really
holding that back, I
think, is that there's
not really a script
interpreter for Go.
And I'm wondering if that's even
a reasonable idea, or if
it's a good idea, or if it's
just completely off the wall?
ROBERT GRIESEMER: I think we
actually had once a partial
interpreter that was
a prototype.
And I know at least of one
internal project where
somebody wrote a package which
you can consider something
like a Go script thingy which
allowed you to run a piece of
code that you would type in
and it behaved like an
interpreter, but that's not
quite what you probably want.
I think it's a feasible thing,
it's just not done--
available in a public forum
that's really usable.
AUDIENCE: I see it as a great
opportunity to bring a lot of
developers and engaging with
Go and expand the audience.
It seems like a pretty
decent fit.
ROBERT GRIESEMER: I think
there's a bunch of questions
that need to be answered when
you do something like that.
Because most languages where you
have an interpreter have a
particular model around
that interpreter.
And, say, Lisp or something like
that which is really sort
of expression-oriented, one
after the other one.
In Go you have the concept of a
package and things that are
simultaneously initialized,
et cetera.
So questions like that need to
be answered-- what does that
mean having interpreter
in that context?
NIGEL TAO: It's just the next
question from the moderator
from Dave Cheney.
Putting aside the Go one
guarantee, if there was one
thing you could remove from the
language what would it be?
ROB PIKE: We usually get
told to put things in,
not take them out.
I'm unhappy with some things,
but we can't fix them.
I was never a fan of the way the
ampersand stuff works to
take the address of a
[? stroke ?] because it's kind
of special-casey and bugs me,
although I admit it's very
nice to use.
I think that the number of ways
you can declare something
is too large and too messy and
needs to be completely
rethought and people
get confused by
it, so that's something.
There's also an unfortunate
thing around the difference
between a null value and a null
interface that confuses
people a lot, and that probably
could use a rethink.
There's not a lot of things I
would take out, but there are
certainly things I
would change if I
were starting over.
You probably have a long list.
ROBERT GRIESEMER: Not
necessarily a long list, but I
think the number of declarations
of a variable, as
Rob mentioned, is
something that I
think needs to be rethought.
There's just too many ways
to do the same thing.
The colon equal operator that
allows you to, quote unquote,
redeclare a variable, is very
convenient, I admit, but it
also introduces a whole
bunch of questions.
In the beginning it introduced
a whole bunch of bugs that we
now circumvent a little bit
because the compiler gives you
great warnings.
But still, I actually have to
think twice every single time
I redeclare a variable that
happens to be also a parameter
of a function, making sure that
I'm really using the same
variable again.
So this is something that I
think we can do better.
There is also a few issues with
embedding of types instructs.
There's some unresolved issues
there I think that maybe we
can do better.
IAN TAYLOR: Personally, I
think I might drop named
result parameters.
I think they were a good idea,
but I think especially in
conjunction with colon equals,
I think they've led to a
certain degree of confusion.
And an idea that Russ
suggested, we
need the Syscall package.
But I don't know if we need to
provide the same compatibility
guarantee for the Syscall
package because that's
essentially an interface between
the language and the
system and systems change.
And we've essentially promised
that we're going to be
compatible with all future
systems, and that's difficult.
DAVID SYMONDS: I'd remove the
complement of the name return
values, which is the naked
return statement.
So if you know your return
values and just write return,
you'll return whatever
those values are.
And I'd say a lot of people are
getting those wrong and I
don't think it's as much
a saving as it looks.
IAN TAYLOR: I would change the
in range loops when you
declare variables.
The variable is reused in each
iteration of the loop which
has zero actual benefit in real
code and can only ever
create bugs where you
accidentally close over that
variable inadvertently and it
gets reused in the wrong part
of the loop necessarily.
And that was something we should
have fixed in Go 1.0,
but didn't.
There's a Go vet thing that
catches a lot of uses of that
now, so that's something.
AUDIENCE: I'd like to thank you
for sticking together the
two languages that I used in
the 1980s, which was C and
occam, into something so I can
actually dig out some more
brain cells to figure
that out.
I got a more modern
question though.
I just got these Google Glass
things and I'm about to write
some code for it.
Should I write Glass code using
Go, or should I be off
[? shucking ?] all of the
examples and doing Java like
everyone else is?
Have you heard of anyone
else trying to do
Glass stuff in Go?
BRAD FITZPATRICK: Are you
talking about the Mirror API?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BRAD FITZPATRICK: That should
work fine in Go.
The Go client library for it
is auto-generated from the
same JSON description of the
API as everything else.
ANDREW GERRAND: And I've
reviewed code by some of the
Glass team that have
written Go code.
So they're using it, so I think
you should as well.
BRAD FITZPATRICK: We actually
had a bug in the API generator
I wrote, and it was actually
generating
malformed Mirror APIs.
And then somebody on the Glass
team mailed me a patch to the
Go generator, so they've
used it at least.
And I know our friend said
he wrote a little Hello
World for his Glass.
AUDIENCE: Well, I'll probably
dive in in the next few weeks.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I work at a company where we're
trying to standardize
our new service side
API on Google Go.
And unfortunately the company's
full of Ruby
fanatics, and so we need some
kind of migration strategy of
how a software server written
in Google Go can communicate
with a software server
written in Ruby.
Looking your RPC package, it
looks like it's mostly made
for Go code to talk
to Go code.
Other than the REST API, is
there any other solutions for
communicating across to
another language?
DAVID SYMONDS: I can recommend
using JSON RPC if you're not
comfortable using RESTs that'll
JSON encode structures
that you can send over HTTP.
AUDIENCE: Is there any
other solution other
than JSON as well?
IAN TAYLOR: You could
use BSON.
[LAUGHTER]
Serious response.
Also, I think Ruby programmers
tend to be pretty comfortable
with the REST API,
in my experience.
Go's HTTP package gives
you great facility for
implementing and connecting
to those.
That would be the most natural
thing, in my opinion.
From what I've seen with Ruby
programmers, a lot of our most
enthusiastic Go programmers in
the open source community are
ex-Ruby programmers.
So I think it's an easy sell
for Rubyists sometimes.
AUDIENCE: Hello again.
I think the thing that attracted
me the most to using
Go or learning more about it was
the fact that it was the
first language I saw that
explicitly acknowledged that
the environment in which most
modern software runs is
changed considerably from
traditional systems.
And the concurrency packages and
structures, I think, are
probably the thing that attracts
the most attention.
I was wondering if you could
just give us a little bit of
insight into anything that might
be upcoming in terms of
concurrency structures and
things that encourage more
easily facilitated
parallelism.
ROB PIKE: There's nothing
actually planned.
Go happened in part because
someone asked me to give a
talk about an old concurrent
language I did at Google.
You can see it on YouTube,
I think.
And then I went back to my
office and I tried to do it in
C++ and it was too frustrating,
so it sort of
planted a seed.
And it was only within a year,
I think, that we started
talking about doing Go.
One of the things that I'd
like to see developed, it
hasn't happened yet, and I've
played with it a little bit,
is the ability to use these
primitives to cross a network.
Some people in the outside have
developed some stuff, and
I wrote a package a few years
ago which I was never happy
with, called NetChan which is
still around, but I don't
recommend it.
The guy at Tumblr whose name
I can't pronounce--
[? ANDREW GERRAND: Putan ?]
[? Mamunkov. ?]
ROB PIKE: He can
pronounce it--
had wrote a system called Go
Circuit, I think, which he
just open sourced which lets
you do some of that and I
think there's a lot
to be done there.
It's one place where, for
example, Erlang does a
beautiful job and we don't
do a job at all.
I'd also like to see packages
develop that are as much a
pattern as like in Sameer's
talk, or in the talk I gave
last year where you see fan
in, fan out, multiplexing,
load balancing, timeouts,
aborts, cancellations.
I think some of that could be
librarified, but the language
isn't strong enough to do it yet
and I would really like to
see a way to make that nice.
There's some new stuff in Go
1.1 about reflection on
channels that makes it maybe
possible to write those now,
and it might be worth trying.
No actual plans.
SAMEER AJMANI: Yeah.
Just to echo and expand on
that, I think we're still
discovering what you can do
with Go with respect to
concurrency.
That as we gain more experience
with how channels
and selecting Go routines
fit together,
patterns are evolving.
They're showing up and we
say, how do I do a send?
But the receiver might have
exited, and therefore I need
to condition it in
the right way.
There's a lot of little
things like this.
You can even write micro
patterns in your code which
allow you to handle these funny
cases and change the way
you think about how your code
is executing and how the
different components
are interacting.
BRAD FITZPATRICK: Sameer
actually ran into my office
the other day all excited that
he had found a new pattern in
Go and he wanted to describe
it and give it a name.
He went through and
described it all.
And I was like oh, no, David
did that months ago.
He was like, oh, bummer.
SAMEER AJMANI: It really
is fun to find
these things, actually.
The more you play with it, and
the more you compose Go
routines and have them
communicate, you really do
find some interesting ways to
plug these things together and
we're still learning.
AUDIENCE: Great, thank you.
NIGEL TAO: Good day again,
back to the moderator.
From Carl Lemons, it has been
said that post-Go 1.0 the Go
Team was spending more
time writing apps in
libraries in Go.
Can you talk about your
experiences with this?
Have you discovered anything
particularly surprising, fun,
or problematic?
BRAD FITZPATRICK: The Garbage
Collector could use some work.
But we actually have people
working on the Garbage
Collector now, so that's good.
ROB PIKE: And the Runtime
Scheduler, too.
The general run time which
includes the Garbage
Collector, the scheduler, the
implementation of channels,
and maps, and all that
stuff, we knew.
So it wasn't surprising,
but it was problematic.
It was really the weak point
of the whole ecosystem.
And most of the performance
improvements that have come in
the past year have been because
of developments in
that area and there's a lot
more to come, so that was
interesting.
We also found that the better
the tools got, the better our
understanding of the programs
got, and therefore the more
stuff we could see and
fix or change,
and we're still learning.
The language in general is young
enough that there really
isn't a Go expert yet.
DAVID SYMONDS: Kind of related
to that, pre-Go 1.0 when we
were still making changes to
the language and to the
standard libraries, Russ Cox
made a tool called Go Fix that
you could run over
source code.
It would read the source code
in, do some manipulation of
the VAC and then write
it back out again.
And that tool really didn't
have any use post-Go 1.0,
because at that point we stopped
changing the language
and libraries.
But inside Google we found it
really great for doing very
large scale cleanups.
The same [INAUDIBLE] tooling
translates great so we can
evolve our code inside Google
that doesn't have that
compatibility guarantee
restriction on it using the
same tools.
And it's great-- we can clean
up millions of lines of code
very easily.
ROB PIKE: And Go Fix is
an example of a source
transformation tool.
And Go's library is mostly
because of the work Robert's
done has this ability to write
amazing source transformation
programs that pick [INAUDIBLE]
up, make some change to it,
write it back out again in a
way that is not only safe, but
also neatly formatted and
performant.
And we're going to see
more and more of
those kind of tools.
I think we've barely scratched
the surface on that.
AUDIENCE: As someone new to
Go, you speak of micro
patterns and things like that.
Beyond just basic language,
documentation and API docks,
where would you recommend to go
to learn more idiomatic Go
and Go patterns and
things like that?
ANDREW GERRAND: I would
recommend if you go to
talks.golang.org, there's, for
instance, Sameer's talk from
today, and David's, and Rob's
talk on concurrency patterns
last year, and all those things
are a great resource.
The Go blog has a long history
of articles that talk about
all kinds of areas of Go
idiom, and we intend to
continue writing
those articles.
DAVID SYMONDS: Reading
the standard library.
ANDREW GERRAND: Oh yeah, and
reading the standard library
is a great way to actually--
a lot of it is extremely well
documented internally.
It's very clean,
very readable.
And a lot of people have told me
that's how they got started
learning Go, just by
reading that stuff.
ROB PIKE: One of the recent
changes, I think it's been
live for quite a while but it's
definitely part of Go
1.1, is that we've pushed a
lot of examples into the
documentation that are not only
visible and tested when
you build the package, but if
you go to Go.doc, or at least
at golang.org, and look at the
documents, the examples are
actually executable right
on the web browser.
And if you see an example that's
close to what you want,
you can play with it in
the browser, modify it
to do what you want.
Run it, check it and all that,
and then just grab that code
and use it, and that's another
good learning library thing.
And of course you know about
the tour, I assume?
Tour [INAUDIBLE]?
ANDREW GERRAND: Yeah.
We really want to improve
all of this stuff.
I think it's already pretty
decent, particularly for a
language as young as it is.
But I certainly have a lot of
ambition to broaden the scope
of our documentation and really
try and share as much
of our experience writing
Go code as possible.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
So I kind of feel like a bastard
for asking this,
especially after you worked
so hard on Go 1.1.
But I've been noticing a few
inconsistencies across
packages which can, of course,
only be fixed with introducing
breaking changes.
So I was wondering,
are you already
collecting stuff like that?
And is Go 2.0 in your head
even a thing right now?
ROB PIKE: We know lots of things
we'd like to break.
And we have a list of things,
some are on the issue tracker
that we would fix or least think
about fixing in Go 2.0.
But Go 2.0 is not on the horizon
in the sense that
we're actively designing it.
But we're definitely collecting
a list of wouldn't
it be nice to fix kind of
things, some of which we've
already mentioned.
Go 2.0 exists so much as a
category in which to throw
issues that we can't
fix today.
But the general attitude is that
we're not going to bother
investing the time thinking
about them or being frustrated
by them, because it's too
far off on the horizon.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to find out
if you have any plans, or I
would like to see some
influences from
Erlang's OTP system.
So it's not just the language,
but the entire runtime system
that has all kinds of hooks.
So, for example, if you have a
channel that's blocked for a
lot longer than you expect, then
you have some profiling
hook which says this is
unexpected, or some debugging
thing that says this
is unexpected.
So a set of tools that work
along with the runtime.
So another example is in
profiling, you just have the
control plane currently.
The statistics only show per
Go routine, how many things
I've called.
But if I wanted to track a user
request that logically
transfers control through
several Go routines and gets
back a request, if I wanted to
profile and say where is this
request taking time?
Through its path through various
Go routines, how can I
taint that particular stream
of control that it's
orthogonal to the Go routine?
So I want some systemic
hooks, basically.
ROB PIKE: We're very aware of
all of those things, and would
love to see them.
The tooling involved is
interesting work.
And I don't mean that
sarcastically, I mean it's
really interesting work.
And some of the other systems at
Google have pieces of that
kind of thing that have not been
adapted to Go yet and I
think would be nice to have.
As far as the Erlang
model, Erlang is a
very different language.
It's interpreted functions are
passable across the network.
I think it does the stuff
you're talking about
beautifully, but Go is
a different language.
It's hard to see how
to fit it in.
But I would love to be proven
wrong and have someone
actually build that environment
for Go.
And it's entirely possible,
but it's certainly not a
priority for us at the moment.
We just have a different
model in mind.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
ANDREW GERRAND: Thanks.
You take one.
NIGEL TAO: Next moderator
question.
We might have touched this
before, but Divox asks, has
the Go team been putting any
thoughts on how to provide
more control over dependencies
and imported packages?
Not having a way to make sure
everyone on the same team has
the same version of third
party packages
can be really painful.
ANDREW GERRAND: Yeah.
I think we've already
discussed that.
BRAD FITZPATRICK: Well, the
thing we didn't discuss is if
you're working with a big team
or whatever, you could also
just check in your dependencies
to your own
version control system.
Then you can have a hermetic
view of the world.
You can sync back to what
the world looked
like two weeks ago.
And when you go to update a
version of your dependencies,
you update it, run
all your tests.
If all your tests pass, maybe
you run it, you do performance
tests on it, then you
check it under your
version control system.
Go Get is nice for
playing around.
But if you're going to do
something serious and you're
actually going to deploy
binaries to production, your
deploy to production scripts
and involve fetching some
random dude's stuff on GitHub.
ANDREW GERRAND: And I'm also
not sure if it's really the
role of the Go tool or the
tooling provided by the
language to actually dictate the
way you manage your code
in a production sense.
One of the virtues of the Go
tool is that it uses Get
Mercurial, Subversion,
[? Bizarre, ?] all tools that
exist and that are
well understood.
And so if you need to build any
tooling around them, you
already understand those tools
that you're already using and
so it should be relatively
straightforward to integrate
those with whatever
system you have.
AUDIENCE: Time for one
more question?
NIGEL TAO: Next one from
Carl Lemons again.
Can you talk about the future
of the run time?
How much of it could and/or
should be rewritten in Go?
ROB PIKE: Quite a bit of it
could be rewritten in Go.
The question also comes up,
why isn't there a compiler
written in Go?
And the answer to both of those
was it got the way it is
because of expediency--
to bootstrap.
You can bootstrap the language
while you're
writing it in itself.
But it's much more cost
effective, especially when
you're thinking of distributing
it once it's up
and running.
Which was always a consideration
for Go to take
an existing language and
write in that, and C
was an obvious candidate.
So there's a compiler written
in C, inside [? GCC ?]
Go is written in C++, uses
the GCC back end.
I think we have more and more
of the pieces necessary to
write the compiler
in Go available.
We've got the Type
Checker now.
There's an SSA package that
can do a lot of the static
analysis for good compilation.
But there's no actual pressure
on our side to do it-- we
don't think it needs to.
As far as the runtime, more
and more of it could be
because the language is getting
stronger and the
efficiencies are coming.
But again, we don't
feel the pressure.
There's no compelling reason to
do it at the moment that I
can see, but I could be wrong.
BRAD FITZPATRICK: I agree.
One compelling reason could
be that our Go compiler is
actually better than our C
compiler at this point, and
lots of things.
IAN TAYLOR: That's not
a compelling reason.
ROBERT GRIESEMER: There's at
least one project that's done
outside which I know of which
is using the existing
libraries that we have for Go
Front and is trying to hook
this up with an LLVM back end.
So that's not a Go compiler
entirely written in Go, but
it's a step in that direction.
ANDREW GERRAND: I think
we're out of time.
We actually have some gifts
for you that we'll be
distributing from the left-hand
side of the stage.
But thank you all for coming,
and please take only one.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]